Alright, you know the issue that we want to make sure
that we think about each time we introduce a new kind
of supervised learning representation is to ask what its preference bias
is. So Charles, can you remind us what preference bias is?
>> Mike researcher bias tells you what it is you
are able to represent. Preference bias tells you something about the
algorithm that you are using to learn. That tells you,
given two representations, why I would prefer one over the other.
So, perhaps you think back what we talked
about with decision trees, we preferred trees where nodes
near the top had high information gain We preferred
correct trees. We preferred trees that were shorter to
ones that were longer unnecessarily and so on and
so forth. So that actually brings up a point
here which is, we haven't actually chosen an algorithm.
We talked about how derivatives work, how back propagation
works, but you missed telling me one very important thing, which is how do
we start? You tell me how to update the weights but, how do I
start out with the weights? Do they all start at zero? Do they all
start out at one? How do you usually set the weights in the beginning?
>> Yes indeed. We did not talk about that, that's, it's
really important. You can't run this algorithm without initializing the weights
to something. Right? We did talk about how you update the
weights but they don't just you know, just start undefined and you,
you can't just update something that's undefined. So we
have to set the initial weights to something. So pretty
typical thing for people to do, is small, random,
values. So why do you suppose we want random values?
>> Because we have no particular reason to pick one set of values over
another. So you start somewhere in the
space. Probably helps us to avoid local minimum.
>> Yea kind of. I mean there's also the issue of Well
if we run the algorithm multiple times if we get stuck, we like
it not to get stuck exactly there again, if do, if you run it
again. So it gives some variability, which is a helpful thing in avoiding
local minimal. And what do you suppose,
it's important to start with small values.
>> Well you just said. In our discussion before that if the weights get
really big that can sometimes lead to
over fitting, because it let's you represent arbitrarily
complex functions.
>> Good. And so, and what is that
tell us about what the preference bias is then?
>> Well if we start out with small random values. That means
we are starting out with low complexity. So that means we prefer Simpler
explanations to more complex explanations. And of course the usual stuff like
we prefer, correct answers to incorrect answers, and so on and so forth.
>> > So, you'd say that neural-nets implement, or maybe we should
say, that neural networks implement a kind of bias that says Prefer correct over
incorrect but all things being equal, the simpler explanation, is preferred.
>> Well, if you have the right algorithm. If the algorithm starts
with small, random values and tries to stop, you know, when you
start over-fitting Then you, cause you're going to start out with the simpler
explanations first before you allow your weights to grow. so you, about that.
>> So this
reminiscent of the principal that is known as Occan's
razor which is often stated as entities should not be
multiplied unnecessarily. And given that we're working with neural
networks, there's a lot of unnecessary multiplication that happens. [LAUGH]
But, in fact, this actually is referring to exactly what we've been
talking about. So this unnecessarily is,
one interpretation of this is that, "Well,
when is it necessary?" It's necessary if you're getting better
explanatory power, you're fitting your data better. So Unnecessarily would
mean, well we're not doing any better at fitting the
data. If we're not doing any better at fitting the data,
then we should not multiply entities. And multiply here means
make more complex. So don't make something more complex unless
you're getting better error, or if two things have similar
error Choose the simpler one, use the one that's less complex.
That has been shown to, if you mathematize this and you use it in
the context of supervised learning, that we're
going to get better generalization error with simpler hypotheses.